We have the special privilege of speaking with Dr. Richard Davidson.
Uh,
Dr. Davidson is the William James and be lost professor of psychology and
psychiatry,
director of the wasteman brain imaging lab and the lab for affect of
neuroscience.
He's also the founder and chair of the Center for investigating healthy minds
and the waysman center at the University of Wisconsin Madison.
Dr. Davidson Ref received his phd from Harvard in psychology and has been at the
University of Wisconsin,
Madison since 1984 he's published more than 290 articles,
many chapters and reviews and edited 14 books.
He's the recent author of the emotional life of your brain and has received
numerous awards including an Nih Research Scientist Award that William James
Fellow award from the American psychological society and the distinguished
scientific contribution award from the American Psychological Association.
Not surprisingly,
he's been named one of the 100 most influential people in the world by Time
magazine in 2006.
He's the past president of the Society for research and psychopathology and of
the Society for psychophysiological research.
He currently serves on the scientific advisory board at the Max Planck Institute
for Human Cognitive and brain sciences,
and as the chair of the psychology section of the American Association for the
Advancement of Science.
So I now turn to our very esteemed experts and emotion interview with Dr.
Richard Davidson on an affect of neuroscience.
So welcome,
Richie.
Thank you for speaking with us today.
Pleasure to be here,
Jim.
Thank you.
I'd like to talk with you,
uh,
just by starting a bit about what first got you interested or started in the
study of emotion.
So perhaps you can tell us a bit more about what first sparked your interest in
this topic.
Sure.
Well,
I always had the conviction that emotion was the juice of life and,
uh,
it was responsible for what makes each of us unique.
Uh,
also,
uh,
what is critical for determining who may be resilient in the face of adversity,
who may be vulnerable.
Uh,
one of the things that also struck me about emotion was the extraordinary
variation across people in how each of us who responds to life slings and
arrows,
and,
um,
that is really one of the central things that has captured my attention over the
years and still remains a central focus of our research.
That's wonderful.
And so speaking of your research,
I'd love to ask a few questions now just about that.
So your work really founded in paved the way for an entire field focused on
looking at emotion through the lens of neuroscience.
And so when you think of an affect of neuroscience,
do you see as the most exciting discoveries
we'll,
uh,
if you look historically at this field,
originally when we all first began,
uh,
this study of emotion from the perspective of neuroscience was relegated to
rodent studies,
um,
uh,
and looking at relatively primitive kinds of emotional processes.
And I think there was a general,
um,
dogma in the field that emotion was something that happens subcortical Lee,
that it was,
um,
more primitive in certain ways.
Then cognition,
which is,
um,
uh,
more,
associated with human rationality,
uh,
and,
associated with cortical function.
And one of the important breakthroughs I think was the understanding that,
um,
the,
uh,
the most evolutionary,
um,
most evolutionarily recent parts of the brain and the parts of the brain that
are distinctly human,
um,
participate very importantly in emotion,
uh,
including,
different areas of the cortex.
And,
uh,
that I think was really important in establishing the fact that emotion is
something that,
um,
uh,
is,
works intimately with cognition.
There are no regions of the brain that are exclusively dedicated to emotion.
And,
um,
the dichotomy between thought and emotion was really more a product of something
that,
um,
philosophers and scientists imposed on nature.
Then a distinction that actually is honored by the brain.
So in your eyes right now,
what do you think are some of the most exciting discoveries of what we do know
about the way in which emotion is organized in the brain or the way in which we
can understand emotion through the lens of neuroscience?
Well,
I think that neuroscience is giving us a handle on ways to think about or ways
to parse variation in emotion or across people,
uh,
in,
um,
uh,
ways that were not obvious from strictly behavioral or,
um,
other kinds of psychological strictly psychological methods.
So for example,
um,
one of the things that we've been very interested in is different parameters of
emotion regulation.
Now,
while emotion regulations certainly has been studied for decades using methods
that don't involve neuroscience,
one of the things that I think neuroscience has given us is um,
uh,
new ways to about regulation.
So one aspect of regulation that we've been studying from a neuroscientific
perspective is recovering.
That is the propensity to recover from a stressful or adverse event.
Uh,
and you can actually track variation or across people in the rapidity of
recovery in different neural systems.
And it turns out that that accounts for very important variants in certain
aspects of behavior that are not captured by conventional methods.
And this is,
uh,
a,
a distinction which I think comes directly from neuroscience and it's helped us
understand not just the brain mechanisms that on July it,
but actually help provide,
um,
a new way of thinking about individual differences in emotion.
Thank you.
And you know,
you mentioned individual differences in emotion.
It makes me think of your work that's really looked at variation and emotion in
people who suffer from emotional disorders.
Um,
and I wonder if you could share this a little bit about your work,
for example,
on depression and the ways in which,
um,
their emotional brains may be different from those who aren't suffering from
depression.
Sure.
And actually that question,
uh,
allows me to also highlight some of the things that I think we can distinctly
learn from a neuroscientific approach.
One of the things that we found in recent work with depressed patients is that
when you present a stimulus that's designed to elicit positive effect,
they actually show a transient response to a positive emotional stimulus.
And this is individuals with a,
um,
a formal DSM diagnosis of major depression.
So these are not simply dysphoric students.
These are real depressed patients,
uh,
and they show a transient response.
But what distinguishes them is that they seem to lack the capacity to have that
response be sustained over time.
Uh,
and um,
uh,
in a healthy person when something positive occurs,
there's a kind of of afterglow,
uh,
that persists.
And that afterglow is something that very importantly accounts for individual
differences in,
um,
in,
in dispositional positive mood.
Uh,
and so in the depressed patients,
they show this transient response,
but it is a response that is not sustained.
And specifically in the brain,
what we see is that that transient,
um,
versus the sustained response can be observed in areas of the ventral striatum
that we know are important,
uh,
in reward,
um,
particularly the nucleus accumbens and also in prefrontal or connectivity.
Uh,
and so what we see in the depressed patients is that they're are unable to
sustain those neural responses over time.
Um,
and the critical difference is the duration of time,
uh,
with which those neural responses are displayed.
And what we see is that in very new research,
which is just impressed now,
um,
among depressed patients who are successfully treated,
what we see is a change in this specific feature of brain activity,
which accounts for changes in or improvements in their profile of positive
effect.
That's fascinating.
So I suggest that we don't just want to look at their responses to a stimulus in
the moment that we,
while it really want to sort of look across time to see what's happening after
that stimulus has gone.
Are they able to sort of hold onto the glow as you said?
Right.
Yeah,
exactly.
And in very new research we are probing the relation between those indices that
we obtained in the laboratory,
in the scanner and experience sampling where we have the same participants
who've been in the scanner out in the world and we text them on their
smartphones at different points during the day.
Uh,
and we can track the extent to which they're positive effect is sustained in the
real world,
um,
uh,
following a positive event.
Fantastic.
So that'll be really interesting potentially to understand the extent to which
these,
you know,
afterglow that they seem to miss might actually be linked to some of their
laboratory responses in their own daily lives where they're confronted with all
kinds of different emotional life events.
Exactly.
Great.
So the last question I wanted to ask you about your research on is really
tracing back to something that you also pioneered along with the field of ethics
of neuroscience.
Um,
your research on meditation and related practices really seem to begin long
before the western scientific community really took hold of these ideas.
And so you being one of the first to really look at meditation.
I wonder what you feel were some of the first indications that meditation may
actually have long lasting effects in the brain.
Well,
um,
I mean,
the honest truth is that,
uh,
meeting certain remarkable people like the Dalai Lama who had been practicing
daily for your entire lives and just being in their presence,
uh,
and,
observing their demeanor as a student of emotion,
uh,
has been,
um,
striking.
Uh,
and most people who have met him,
um,
report very similar things that they're,
uh,
just,
I'm quite impressed with,
uh,
who he is,
his comportment as a human being,
so to speak.
Um,
uh,
and,
and really what they are commenting on our,
his emotional qualities.
Uh,
and I think that,
um,
uh,
in the laboratory we have seen that individuals who spent quite a long period of
near adult life,
um,
doing formal meditation practices designed to cultivate both mindfulness as well
as explicitly cultivates certain positive characteristics like compassion,
um,
have a very different profiles of neural responses,
uh,
in a variety of different kinds of paradigms.
And so,
um,
both at baseline as well as in response to certain kinds of emotional stimuli.
And so those early studies that we did in,
uh,
the first one was long term practitioners was published in 2004.
Uh,
we observed striking differences in the brains of these individuals,
which provided some initial clues that there might be a,
there there that is,
that there might be something,
um,
really,
uh,
quite interesting that is being affected in the brains of these individuals who
spent a long time cultivating these,
what I would call positive habits of mind.
And what do you see now is this research,
at least in the western scientific community has really kind of taken flight.
What do you see right now,
some of the most exciting findings that you're reading about it,
either in your lab or in the works of others?
Well,
uh,
I would say two kinds of really exciting new findings.
One is,
um,
the really extraordinary,
changes that one can see even with a very short amount of practice in both the
function and the structure of the brain.
That is,
you don't need a lot of practice,
um,
to produce measurable changes.
We don't know how long those changes will last.
And my own intuition is that the only last thing,
the extent that people keep practicing these methods,
it's kind of like physical exercise.
No one would think that two weeks of physical exercise is going to change the
body in ways that endure once a person stops exercising.
Uh,
so I think the same thing will be true here,
but it is remarkable that we and others,
for example,
have seen changes in as little as two weeks of practice,
30 minutes a day,
and otherwise completely naive participants in a true randomized control design.
Um,
so that's one thing that I think is really,
uh,
interesting.
Uh,
I'll,
I'll mention three very quick things.
The second thing or changes in,
um,
uh,
in,
um,
peripheral biological systems biology below the neck,
uh,
that may play an important role in health,
physical health and illness,
particularly in altering,
um,
pathways that are important in inflammation.
We know that inflammation is very,
before many chronic diseases like diabetes,
cardiovascular disease,
asthma,
those are all illnesses with a very significant inflammatory component.
And then there's some reason to believe that certain kinds of meditation
practices affect,
um,
a cascade of signaling systems that impact inflammation and reduce it.
And there are many studies now published in the scientific literature,
uh,
which was showing that the third thing very briefly is,
um,
work with very young children.
We know that the brains of young children are more plastic than the brains of
older adults.
Uh,
and there's some reason to believe that these kinds of strategies may be
particularly effective with very young children.
And we're doing work beginning in preschool,
children with kids age four and five years of age.
Uh,
and um,
some of the changes that we see with very short amounts of intervention,
um,
uh,
are quite remarkable.
And,
um,
uh,
we,
think that this may be an optimal time to begin these kinds of practices to set
children offs on a very positive trajectory.
That's wonderful.
So speaking of trajectories then,
what I wanted to ask you a little about is sort of where you see the trajectory
or face of the future of emotion headed.
So what might be in your mind,
some of the most exciting next steps in store for us?
Well,
uh,
I think that,
um,
uh,
from a hard no scientific perspective in terms of the biology of emotion,
one of the most exciting things is integrating systems level neuroscience with
molecular neuroscience,
uh,
and actually looking at alterations in gene expression that are associated with
different profiles of emotion.
Um,
gene expression in both humans and you know,
awesome and animal work where it can be exact with greater specificity and
there's a whole set of complicated issues which need to be unpacked there.
Uh,
so I think that's going to be very important.
I think that,
um,
the role of,
conscious versus unconscious emotion is something that,
um,
has only really begun to be explored.
Uh,
but,
uh,
it seems like there's an awful lot of affective processing that occurs.
Non-Consciously and one of the critical questions that we still know very little
about is what the role of punches experience is in aspect,
uh,
and,
um,
how Mike conscious experience particularly play a role in the regulation of
affect.
Um,
and so that's going to be a very important area to unpack.
A,
and,
um,
finally I would say that,
uh,
virtually everything we know about emotion is based the study of a,
um,
a very small sliver of humanity.
Um,
uh,
and it is,
individuals from the west who are highly educated,
uh,
and,
um,
uh,
come from a very select social strata.
And I think that,
um,
looking at emotion and other parts of the world is going to be very important
because I'm not convinced that the dimensional structure of emotion that we talk
about as western psychologists on is necessarily,
uh,
actually how we were designed.
Um,
uh,
and,
it may be a structure that we've imposed or that we've learned here in the west,
but,
um,
I'm not sure that these are necessarily the most fundamental dimensions of
emotion.
And so I think that there's a lot that's going to be discovered by extending
our,
um,
uh,
investigation beyond western culture.
So then the last question I have for you is,
what advice would you have for students and people more generally who are
interested in studying or embarking in emotion?
Well,
one of the things I often tell my students is,
um,
uh,
I,
for any serious student of emotion at some point early in their career,
it's really important that they work with organisms that can't speak either very
young children or animals.
Uh,
and,
um,
the reason I say that is because I think that too much of what we think we know
about emotion has been inferred from self report measure.
Uh,
and I think it's really important that a serious student of emotion work with a,
an organism that cannot speak,
uh,
and,
be forced to make inferences about emotion from something other than language.
Um,
and so I would say that that's one thing that I would highly recommend.
And another thing that I would highly recommend is that serious student of
emotion actually take on some kind of systematic investigation of their own
interior rt,
um,
their own emotional processes because I think that it actually can be very
helpful,
uh,
in,
um,
uh,
in understanding the nature of emotion more generally.
Well,
thank you so much for speaking with us today.
Richie.
Uh,
this concludes our experts in emotion interview with Doctor Richie Davidson from
the University of Wisconsin.
Madison.